we saw something in overtime on Sunday
that we hadn't seen before and that was
Kirk Cousins finally stepping up and
making big throw in big spot he had two
of them he had the throw to Adam Thielen
the 43-yard it set up the touchdown and
then on third and goal from the five
after that that latest effort at the
stupid sweep play got bottled up
he found Kyle Rudolph in the back of the
endzone for the touchdown and look Kirk
Cousins I don't know that it it
dramatically changes the body of work
but it definitely gives us a a current
recent chapter to look at and say hmmmm
maybe something a little bit different
here that well that's right yeah I mean
I do think it does that it gives you a
little confidence right I mean the
moment wasn't too big for him he wasn't
like overwhelmed and he had people and
pressure around him I mean these throws
he's making where we're watching here on
TV they're high level throws it's not
like it was bad coverage and people were
screaming down the field wide open so
you know again yes his Kirk Cousins
gonna be like deshaun Watson Erma Holmes
and be like hey guys jump on my
shoulders also even when the protection
is bad I'll scramble around and throw
lasers all over the field and just carry
you know he can carry you within a
certain limit and when they run the ball
like we saw them do which was surprising
to me so it forced the Saints to do some
things on the defensive side of the ball
gave them some favorable matchups one on
one wise and with Filan bein looks like
a hundred percent healthy you know
Cousins has proved this year when he
wants to throw down the ball down the
field he's pretty accurate and feelin
and digs can go get it
let alone you know Kyle Rudolph in that
run game showing up too and it really is
a total team effort where the defense
has to be clicking yes the running game
has to be going the receivers have to do
what they're supposed to do and that's
what cousins called it after the game on
Sunday a total team effort but he got
the game ball and Mike Zimmer the head
coach of the Vikings explained yesterday
why that decision was made here's the
question that was posed along with
Zimmer's answer what was it like to be
able to share that moment with Kirk in
the locker room after the game you know
give him the game ball after he came
through for you in such a big spot yeah
I think it was you know it was just
[Music]
you know him solidifying himself you
know with all of the bad rhetoric that
he gets all the time you know about this
or that you know I just felt like you
know it was time to tell a lot of people
that he's our guy and he did it you know
it's a funny contrast to a couple of
years ago in case keenum was getting it
done for the Vikings week after week
after week after week right Zimmer was
very restrained righty I'd never get it
right yeah never giving him credit the
old Parcells trick like I'm gonna keep
dangling the carrot so you keep doing it
kind of a break to actually you know i
because i think the Parcells mindset
would be keep keep poking the guy in the
rear end to get him to keep doing it you
don't want him to all of a sudden think
he's pretty good you want him to to hear
the critics and find that motivation
that comes from trying to shut everybody
up so kind of a kind of a against what
we would expect from a Zimmer who was a
Bill Parcells disciple well I think he's
probably at this point going man the
guy's had to deal with this pressure for
a long long time and he's had this you
know needle you know so-called needle
poking in on the side for a long long
time let's flip the switch and maybe see
after a win if we can all gain
confidence and he can gain comments and
be like oh what what I am the man that's
right I'm made for primetime you know I
think he's trying to take advantage of
some momentum this clip in the locker
room with him saying I got three words
you like that and the way the offensive
line reacts like it gives me chills to
watch it this is the kind of stuff I'm
missing and then I felt locker room but
I only got three words for you and then
like for his right tackle O'Neill and
everybody to go crazy I mean look at him
he's like he cares like you that can
inspire a football team and I think
that's what Zimmer's doing he's trying
to like kind of feed off the old
momentum and and tell everybody let's
let's get behind one of our good leaders
and workers and Kirk Cousins Zimmer
deserves a lot of credit he knows what
he's doing and his defense was awesome
in that game the other day Mike my first
reaction to hearing what Zimmer had to
say was this is a far cry from the Steve
Young monkey off his back moment that
was a superb
this is one game one moment two throws
in overtime because before that it was
not over the top great stuff he had
blown coverage where he hit at him
feeling down the field in the third
quarter but even the the demeanor of
Kirk Cousins we talked about this
yesterday the demeanor that we saw from
him on the sidelines as overtime was
approaching not that not that kind of
that that swagger that we saw I remember
in the Lions game where he knew he was
gonna have to come out and make a throw
and he did make a big throw gutsy throw
down the field just to Phan Diggs he
seemed a little bit freaked out and
maybe maybe Zimmer Zimmer's assessment
is all this guy needs is one crack yeah
and if he can get through one crack the
dam can break and I think he's banking
on that by rallying around him now that
he stepped onto the big stage and made
the big throw maybe it is the first step
of many not just an aberration I think
that's what he's hoping for that this
takes them somewhere to where the
offense feeds off of his energy and
feeling and digs and everybody you know
has a chance to explode this weekend
behind davon cooks running and all of
that and you know hey I got to give like
Zimmer credit to Mike because you know
one of the things I've always say I'm a
little concerned with Zimmer he's a
little bit of like hey this is what we
do and you know that we're just gonna be
sound and we're not gonna mess up and
that's the way he did some things
outside his comfort zone last weekend
you know doubled Michael Thomas did some
combination coverages took away some
real staples of the Saints offense right
I mean hey you know hey all year when we
watch Saints football I've seen Jared
cook Michael Thomas and Alvin Kamara
just abused the middle of the field
right catch balls option routes always
over the that was not existed in this
game and that was cuz I'm Mike Zimmer
and his coaching he took away some of
those completions that Sean Payton and
Drew Brees just feast off of on a weekly
basis and like a lot of credit goes to
Zimmer of course Kirk Cousins and we all
doubted the Vikings there's no way I
thought they were gonna win that game
and and they did it 1:32 whoa
you know I that was not supposed to be
used hi there is somebody who I'm gonna
kick in a certain area that's gonna be
very painful when he knows who
it is and it's not you all right yeah
you can take that down now believe them
32 years ago the Vikings played the
Saints in New Orleans on a Sunday they
won they had to go to San Francisco the
following Saturday it's a quick
turnaround right and and you got a fly
home from New Orleans you got to fly to
San Francisco you got to get everything
worked out logistically you got to get a
game to get ready for when you're going
against a team that is the number one
seed in the conference here's Mike
Zimmer yesterday when he was asked
whether he's upset about having to go to
San Francisco and face the 49ers on a
short week it's similar to playing a
Monday night game and then you gotta get
ready for a Sunday game obviously we're
going going out to the west coast said
I'd be a little bit different but hey
it's playoff time
you know it's big-boy football now and
you know what I I think he has learned
from what happened two years ago we've
been talking about how he's more
flexible he's changing his defense he
seems like he's differently it's
everything you did from week one for
week 17 is gone now from your it's got
to be gone from your mindset about what
you're gonna do because everything
you've done that's what they're going to
be looking for to use it against you to
game plan against you so you have to
flip on everything go down you have to
be creative and and I think that's where
that's work that's why Bill Belichick
has six Super Bowl championships because
he consistently has done that right and
Zimmer's figured it out you know it took
him a couple of playoff cycles to figure
it out but he has no no did no question
you know as our our old famous saying
you got a self scout thyself especially
playoff time you got to make sure that
you don't have like glaring tendencies
in certain formations or certain
personnel sets let me change that up you
better do that verse Kyle Shanahan
because Kyle Shanahan like a McDaniels
or Belichick if he finds a formation
that yo this is predictable they're
gonna get in this defense watch out
he'll design 20 plays to just screw that
defense over so you got to do things
like that to have a changeup certainly
and I do I give Zimmer a lot of credit
everything's out the window this time of
the year like he said it's big big boy
football time like no schedules hey
coaches you know sorry
screw your family right now we're here
all day that's just the way it is and
we're gonna gameplan we're gonna push
the envelope and we might do some things
that we normally wouldn't do because it
is a desperation win or go home type of
things so this is gonna be exciting I'm
really excited for all the matchups but
really excited to be on the field with
your Vikings watching you nervous and
then of course my buddy Kyle Shanahan
and the 49ers being there too really
pumped to be a part of it and do our
football night in America from on the
field in San Francisco
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports